it's funny you mentioned that
um michelangelo and steve jobs
you know a set of ideas represents the
person's work so we talked about
algorand which is a super interesting
set of technologies
but you know he did also win the
touring award you have a bunch of you
have a bunch of
ideas that are you know
seminal ideas so can we talk about
cryptography for a little bit
what is the most beautiful idea in
cryptography or computer science
or mathematics in general asking
somebody who has
explored the depths of all
a few contenders
[Laughter]
and uh either your work or or
what other words let's leave my work
aside
yes and and uh so but one
powerful idea and is a
both an old idea in some sense and a
very very modern one
and in my opinion is this idea of a
one-way function
so a function that easy
to evaluate so given x you can compute f
of x easily
but given f of x is very hard to go back
to x
okay think like
breaking a glass easy reconstruct the
glass hard
frying an egg easy for the side egg
to go back to your original egg hard
if you want to be extreme killing a
living being
unfortunately easy the other way around
very hard and so the fact that the
notion
of a function which you have a recipe
that is in front of your eyes to
transform an accent to
f of x and then from f of x even though
you see the recipe to transform it
you cannot go back to x that in my
opinion is one of the most
elegant and momentous
notions that there are and is a
computational notion because of the
difficulties in a computational sense
and it's a mathematical notion because
we were talking about function
and is so fruitful because that is
actually the foundation of all
cryptography and let me tell you it's an
old notion
because very often in any mythology
that we think of the most powerful gods
or goddesses
are the ones of x and the opposite of x
the gods of love and death and when you
take
opposites they don't just you know
erase one another you create something
way more powerful
and they this one-way function is
extremely
powerful because essentially becomes
something that is easy for the good guys
and bad for
the but hard for the bad guys
so for instance in pseudo-random number
generation
the easy part of the function
corresponds you want to generate bits
very quickly
and hard is predicting what the next bit
is
it says jail it doesn't look the same
one is x f of x
going from x for x to x r what does do
predicting bits
by a magic of reductions in mathematical
um this simple function
morphs itself into sort of handling
generation there's a simple function
morphs themselves in digital signature
scheme in which
digital designing should be easy and
forging should be hard
again a digital signature is not going
from x to f
x but the magic and the richness of this
notion is meant that
it is so powerful it morphs
in all kinds of incredible constructs
and uh in both these two opposites
coexist
the easy and the hard and in my opinion
is a very very elegant notion so
that simple notion ties together
cryptography
like you said pseudo-random number
generation
you